this session it's Sofia [ __ ] papa she
will be talking about the Eurasia
because this arrows and poverty testing
and mobility coding so my name is Sofia
Roth Kournikova and this is joint work
with Naga runs AV from Haifa University
and with my student mitten Varma who is
quantified and he is graduating and
looking for a postdoc so please so our
main motivation for this line of work
was to study Sabina rooms that are
resilient to adversarial corruptions in
the input and specifically will focus on
the property testing model so this is
gonna be standard picture over under my
diagram so the way you usually think
about it so it's sorry over something
your time Algrim so the way I usually
think about it well it's a randomized
algorithm that gets a very very long
input and it's allowed to probe some
locations in the input so query and get
back the what's written in this location
menon runs for a very short time and
outputs an approximate answer and our
goal is to study the quality of
approximation versus the resources that
the algorithm uses so for example the
number of queries or the running time
however so the question that we asked
was is it always reasonable to assume
that the input is intact
so it could be the case that there are
errors in the input or erasers and so
these are the types of captions that
we're going to consider so could be the
case that they outgrow all the
algorithms running it's getting wrong
answers to the queries so specifically
we wanted to understand what happens
when there are erasers in the input so
in this case there is some parameter
alpha given to you so you know that
there is at most alpha fraction of the
input that's eerily
and in the case of errors at most alpha
fractional input is my
by adverse early before the algorithm
starts running and the algorithm does
not know in advance what's erased or
modified so when it queries the location
whether here so it gets back well no
you're not allowed to know what's
written there or it's it's a race so can
we still perform the computational tasks
that we want to perform in particular
will focus on properly testing so this
is the property testing model that we
all know and love so was the first
considered by urban problem Sudan and
formally defined by border crosser and
on so we're in this model so our
randomized algorithm has to solve the
decision problem approximately so the
answer to the actual problem is yes or
no and the algorithm has to accept with
probability at least two-thirds of the
answers here yes and reject with
probability at least two-thirds if the
answer is far from us and specifically
the distance is measured in terms of the
fraction of the input that has to be
modified to make the answer change from
no to yes so this is the standard
property testing model and in the middle
here when the input is epsilon close to
being yes instance we don't care what
the other outputs
so the analogous model for testing with
erasers is as follows so we have our
parameter parameter alpha so we have a
most alpha fraction of the input bits
erased or input characters erased and so
we want to answer yes if we can fill in
erasers in such a way that the answer
could have been yes and if any way we
fill the input who fill in barriers the
answer is far from main yes then we want
to say you know hyperbole and otherwise
we don't care so now there are two
parameters so the fraction of errors and
the distance which is our approximation
parameter did we care about are there
any questions about the model
completions well so okay so it depends
so the question is whether so whether
you if the sublunary is crucial because
otherwise if we just try all possible
completions so yes so the question is
also whether you care about just the
running time or the query complexity
right so if you care about the order
complexity so once you read the whole
input you you can figure out whatever
you want right so but we could also care
about there any time in any other
questions
so what about errors so the appropriate
model is called polar and property
testing and it's been defined by per
Nastran Rubenfeld actually much earlier
than the Serratia resilient testing so
here if we think in terms of adversarial
corruptions so we can just say okay at
most alpha fraction of the input is
incorrect and analogously we want to say
so we have our yes instances and
instances which are epsilon far from yes
but now we could also have alpha
fraction of our input incorrect so what
we ask is to accept with probability at
least two-thirds if we are alpha close
to a yes instance right so if we need to
change at most alpha fraction on the
input to get to some input on which the
answer is yes and if we're epsilon far
then we would like to reject
are there any questions so what are the
relationships between the models so our
pipes on Tortola testable is the
smallest faster than a class so this is
the hardest thing to do and alpha U is
resilient ly Epsilon testable is a
bigger class so you can think so it's
obvious that tormented testable is
contained in nature resilient ly
testable because you can just fill the
ridges in arbitrary ways so it's obvious
that this class is contained in this
class and epsilon testable right so is
yet a bigger class it's also it's
contained
so this one is contained in the bigger
class for obvious reasons but it's less
obvious whether containments restrict
and it turns out that the are strict so
Fisher and port no separated standard
testing from polar and testing and so
when we define this a very resilient
testing we separated it we separated it
from standard testing but
so the question that remained was to
separate Turin testing from original
resilient testing and this is what I'll
show you today
so specifically there exists the
property of n-bit strings and ranges of
parameters alpha and epsilon such that
this property can be alpha resilient K
epsilon tested with constant for
complexity meaning the query complexity
of the tester depends only on alpha and
epsilon but not on the like length of
the input but the same property in order
to be tolerant test thoroughly tested
requires many queries so in particular
polynomial in the length of beam
I don't nee questions so for the
standards so the separation from erasure
to just stand there
testing is there it's a similar result
of the similar form right so and so
there it's basically it's linear
actually um it's the tilde of leaner at
least so maybe not the way we written it
but we know how to make it near so it's
not natural so it's kind of constructed
to be a PCPs right um I'm going to show
you so it's a it's a good question
whether you can do something like this
with a natural property so the Fisher
for thoughts everything example should
be is a fitting example of one of the
two basically yeah basically it was for
most yeah it was almost a separating
example for so let me go back for
testable versus eurasia resilient just
testing so it's just kind of a small
note in the paper to define the
Brazilian model you're using and model
so but we weren't sure how to separate
this
other questions
so so this is what we'll talk about
today but most of the talk I'm going to
talk I'm going to describe constant
versus something that depends on end but
there has very good dependence on end
and then I'll mention what's needed to
make it independent normal so and so the
main tool is locally list original
decodable codes so I'm going to show you
the separation but let me just talk
about this so hopefully list decodable
codes have been studied extensively
there are many papers but so when we
basically decided we we need the same
codes with the readers to our surprise
we didn't find anything so in would thus
two constraints so we wanted them to be
locally which I'll explain and we want
them wanting them to be able to handle
list rate so to be able to talk with
lists so in this context only some
exceptions only only errors not erasers
were previously studied and it's not the
case without the lockable is a
restriction so if you look at these
decodable codes when they did study both
errors and erasers so the question that
and if we wanted to answer for our
separation was can locally lease
decodable codes codes perform better
with readers than were errors in
Somerset
so let me define what the locally
alliteration decodable code is so this
definition is basically and not the same
or just accept that there are errors
leisure is not errors as the standard
locally and is decodable code so an
error correcting code is a map from
message space to the code word space so
here we have parameters alpha which is
the bound on the fraction of a reader's
list size which is the bound on the size
of the list and Q which is a bound on
the number of queries that were allowed
so the input to the algorithm is a code
word and it can have a resource right so
we denote Avengers so the first
condition is the diffraction of various
bits in the input has to be at most
alpha so then the algorithm itself lists
the local list original coder is allowed
to query some positions of the input
word and specifically at most K
positions then it runs for a short time
and then what it outputs is a bunch of
other algorithms it's all at most all of
them and each of these algorithms
basically is an implicit representation
of one of the decoded code words so this
is the actual condition that one so with
high constant probability for every
message whose encoding agrees with our
input on all the non erased bits we want
to make sure that one of the algorithms
implicitly gives this code word so for
again so for every code word that could
have been obtained who could have been
the map to this by erasing some bits we
want to make sure there is some
representation some decoding event and
the decoding is one of the South worms
and so what do we want from this
algorithm we want to make sure that this
corresponding Algrim if it's given
oracle access to this input it will be
able to decode required bits so I can
ask it
was the I bit of the original message
again it's supposed to answer with
hyperbole okay so this is the main
requirement right so and again so we
have algorithm a list of algorithms here
as opposed to the list of actual colors
because code words are huge right so
this is the local mono and so the final
condition is that each algorithm is also
local it makes most Q queries so this is
a locally list earlier decodable codes
and so the local lists the codable codes
are defined the same way except that you
can have errors
so let me talk about the Hadamard code
so this is the code which is very good
locally list erasure the code above code
except that it has low rate so we're
going to use it in our example so so the
Hadamard code Maps K bits to 2 to the K
bits and given input X which is a K bit
vector it mapped maps it to all the
evaluations of the linear function with
coefficients being x-rayed so X evaluate
so this function evaluated at all points
all points why
so and this code is actually impossible
to decode when the fraction of errors is
greater or equal to 1/2 because
basically all code words have distance
1/2 so
so let's try to understand how easy it
is to to decode this code so with errors
so local is decoding of Hadamard code is
the famous result Bible 11 and basically
what they showed is that for any
fraction of errors which is up to 1/2
that it cannot be more than 1/2 so up to
the bound that you can achieve you can
locally this decoded with lists of size
1 over 1/2 minus alpha so this is how
close were to the 1/2 threshold so
that's word and the similar number of
queries and it turns out that both of
this functions are tight right so you
cannot go below this in terms of list
sizes or in terms of the number of
queries we try to understand the same
old with respect to erasers so you can
have more erasers than you can have
errors so you can get for any Alpha
which is some constant below 1 you can
have that number of erasers and you can
decode even with a huge number of years
and so here the difference is that we
don't have squared and so this is also
how close we are to the threshold to the
bound with which we can still decode and
the same bound here and it turns out
that the number of queries is actually
tight and it's implicit in the recent
paper by Greenberg Vitiello and viola
but the list size were not sure if it's
stack
and so no notice the desert these are
better dependences here than here so
there's no square and so improvement in
the eraser you know that you will not
give that it's a faulty query and yes
yes so that's the kind of the original
hope was that you can get lots of
advantage from it and in the case of
Hadamard code you can get advantage but
so there are bigger questions that
remain so basically how much advantage
you can get can you actually get a
drastically better rate with those codes
so you can see one year one when there
is in there a jury you can see it but
that's not easy
I suppose
so so what does it have to do with the
original property testing question so
how does separating images from errors
in localized decoding help with
separating them in properly testing so
let me start by giving some building
blocks which go into separation and then
I'll show you the picture so there are
there are some properties which are very
hard to test but easy to decide exactly
so one example of such class of
properties is 3-cnf properties so here
we've given a formula one variables we
see it's the 3-cnf formula and it has a
linear number of clauses and the
property that we want to consider it
won't whether our input satisfies the
property or not is set of satisfying
assignments to this formula it's so
these are our yes instances so it turns
out that there is a class of formulas
like this such that absolute testing
this class reporter Louis requires a
linear number of queries ok so which is
as hard as it gets in the sub linear
world however it's easy to see that if
you want to decide exactly whether our
input satisfies this formula or not or
not you can do it in linear time so for
any 3-cnf formula
so there is a linear size circuit that
decides this is a special class of
properties that we're going to start
with another component that we're going
to use is a PC piece of proximities so
think about testing with advice so this
PCP is opportunities or aggravated as
PCP piece we're defined by Benson at all
and simultaneously by general and
Rheingold and so basically we have a PCP
verifier which is sub linear time out
there and gets input to the original
guess corey access to the original input
and corey access to some proof string
and if the original input has the
property then there has to exist the
proof for which the verifier accepts
with high probability
however if the input is far from having
the property then no matter what the
proof is the verifier has to reject with
high probability and we don't care what
happens on the inputs which are in
between X and so between the property
and epsilon program
so what they showed is that every
property which is decidable with a
circuit of size M has PCP of proximity
of length roughly linear in and constant
complexity so in other words question in
other words so what does it imply about
test increasing in the properties so it
turns out turns out so basically okay so
we know that if we want to test this
class of properties we need a linear
number of forests so without the proof
but if we have a proof we can test it
with constant query complexity and the
proof that we need is roughly of linear
size so we have this interesting
property which is easy to test with the
proof but very hard to test without the
proof so somehow we would like to
amplify it to get the separation that we
want so translated into our setting and
so this pcp ideas is from Fisher and
Fort know they used a different property
lots of properties but basically they
and their starting point was similar
type of separation so now so in our
separating property we're going to use
the code the so specifically we'll try
harder Mart first so this is appropriate
so we're going to define it as follows
so first part of the property of the
input string is called the plain part so
there we'll just we'll pick some string
X that satisfies the hard frisian
appropriate and which is going to
repeated certain number of times so
we're going to repeat it to balance this
two parts so we want this part to be a
constant if a constant factor larger
than the encoded part so we want it to
be really hard to make changes to this
input X in the sense that you have to
pay lots in in the distance if you make
changes in X
so and the second part is just going to
be the encoding of the string X and the
proof so PI of X is the proof on which
the PCP verifier accepts X so in order
for the string to be in the property in
a separating propery X has to be in the
face inappropri right so if it's in the
pre CNF properly then there is a proof
on which the verifier is going to upset
so pi has to be that proof and then we
take x concatenated with the proof and
we just encode it with a locally list
area decodable code so for the purposes
of this talk we're just going to use the
Hadamard code but if we get a code with
a better rate then it implies a stronger
separation
so this is the property any questions
about the property
okay so so now we would like to show
that we can actually test it within a
very silly and Algar so and the idea is
that if a constant fraction so let's say
one-fourth of the encoding is preserved
we can still locally ready to code so
here's a high-level overview of the
tester so it's going to open a list
aerator the code they had emerged in
coding and it's going to get a list of
algorithms and so for each algorithm is
going to check two things so first it's
going to check whether the plane part so
this the first part is actually
repetitions of the decoded X and it's
just going to do it by something random
bits right so it's going to query our
decoding right so our decoding algorithm
on some random bits of X and it's just
going to check with the corresponding
random bits here to make sure that
they're actually repetitions of X and
it's also going to check that the PCP
verifier accepts this x concatenated
with the PI of X which is implicitly
decoded in order to do this it's just
going to run the PCP verify which is
going to ask a constant number of bits
so it has to decode only a constant
number of bits here also and then at the
end it's going to accept if some
algorithm on the list satisfies both
checks it's the one we run with that
Algrim everything worked out so both
checks passed
so the South Graham has query complexity
comes in query complexity it so again
just to do both checks you only need to
decode the constant number of bits it's
a little query Chow where I'm gonna come
to the number of bits
any questions about this you need to
check whether PI of X is also the proof
of this eggs so you said you can check
whether this X these two are equal to
each other yeah so this is the second
check so the first the first check
actually makes sure that this is these
are repetitions of this X indeed right
and the second one checks that so this
proof is actually I accepted so this is
the second check
okay so actually and so let me maybe say
say if you're worried so I don't have
like a detailed proof why works so let
me just kind of tell the intuition
so if actually we have a code word so if
I have the input which satisfies the
separating property then the checks are
going to pass right so there's going to
be some algorithm on the list of the
decoded algorithms for which for which
they we actually have the original input
which satisfies the property and for
that algorithm we actually go in to
passport checks does it make sense so
and the slightly harder to prove thing
is that if our input is far from
satisfying the separating property then
it's going to imply that what we have
here is the repetitions is far from
being a repetition of some string X
which satisfies the 3-cnf we'll bring it
so because this part is slightly longer
or a constant factor longer basically
there has to be lots of mistakes in this
part and then one of those two techs is
going to fail at least one was to check
is going to fail for every single proof
it's a premises and for every single
decoding of X and
so this was the algorithm itself so now
what's the idea of why it's hard to test
orally well the idea is that we can
reduce standard testing of the free CNF
property to tollerant testing of the
separating property so why is this so
given a string x we can just simulate
access to the repetitions of X plus just
all 0 string it's so old zero string is
in fact can be viewed as a Hadamard any
Hardiman code word would have half of
the bits incorrect so
how the main coding is correct so if our
tester is supposed to handle such a high
rate of encoding then it's supposed to
be able to tell us whether the original
string X is in a pristine appropriate or
far from to the frizziness robbery
however we know that without advice just
testing everything appropriate so this
is just testing without advice right so
it requires linear number of queries so
therefore in order to be able to test
this we have to do number of queries
which is varied mechanist because we
encoded but blew up the length of the
input so by making it to to the original
little right so we still need little n
queries right so but this is log of the
length of this whole input
so this is the idea
so what we've proved is that the
separating property is really resilient
he testable with a constant number of
queries but it requires some number of
queries which depends on the lamp on the
input to test tolerantly
so normally there's always so here your
ears was one quarter and your hair's as
a hat right so you so we're comparing
apples to apples actually so so
therefore corresponding parameters alpha
so it was
let's see sorry
yeah I guess we can so if I make a half
half of these bits we can make them have
both of them wait so they have two sorry
yeah I guess I didn't put the same thing
on the slides so let me go back to the
quarter so it can be for any comes from
here right so yeah you're right so I
should not have put it over here right
so what can put half there right so if
we have one half of the encoding right
so we can still the code in fact we can
decode for any constant as long as we
have any constant preserved which is
constant fraction of the original
yeah but on the other hand I mean so you
so yeah so the results actually have
worked for the same for the
corresponding parameters thanks so for
the corresponding alpha and epsilon wood
for which the fortune my question is
when you're doing an air crash if you
corrupt how so that's the point right so
you if you corrupt half by introducing
errors you cannot recover anything right
so basically we're equally close to
interesting cases when the error is less
than 1/2 for the for the errors right so
but what we're using exactly this
exactly they have the fact that with the
same error rate you can decode if they
start with the same corruption rate we
can decode if the corrections are errors
but we can know the code that the
corruptions the other where okay good
good somebody's paying attention so we
can decode if the corruptions our ears
but with the same rate would connote the
code if the captions are errors so this
is exactly what we're using it's
modified by than when you with it it
says invalid actually the first modified
so you see I know about that so it's not
surprising you're saying it's not
surprising yeah so it's so this is this
is what we were hoping for so when we
look at this we said okay if we have a
code like this where you can decode with
the readers but you cannot decode the
code with corruptions for the same rate
then we're done but so it turned out
that nobody studied these things and
moreover it's not so easy because
they're they're kind of look there's
like a lady involved here and so I'll
get to the open questions so they're I
guess there's a big open question
whether you can improve on the rate
any other questions
so this is well approved so tollerant
testing is harder than usual resilient
testing in general so but I guess this
law login is a little bit disappointing
so what I'm going to get is and to some
larger power so what are the challenges
in trying to strengthen the separation
so what I mentioned before is that if
there exists a code that is locally
decodable from an alpha fraction
operators with the following conditions
so this list size and the number of
queries are constant right so they only
depend on alpha and it has rate which is
this little and over big an rate so the
which is inverse polynomial then there
is a stronger separation it's so
constant versus n to the C but the
problem is that the existence of such a
code is an open question and specific
more specifically the corresponding
question for the case of errors is the
holy grail of the research and local
decoding so this is what they're trying
to get so there are actually better
slightly better codes with slightly
better rate than Hadamard but they're
not good enough and they are stuck there
so I guess one big open question is
whether we can do better with erasers so
if there is yours are obviously easier
that may be maybe somebody can come up
with the code that actually has inverse
paranormal rate so all these conditions
but woody research
then we would be done okay so but we
couldn't do this right so because we
didn't break this open question so this
is what we did instead so first of all
so web there is an observation that
queries of the PCP verifier can be made
nearly uniform over the proof indices so
basically the verifier can be made in
such a in such a way that just samples
what it needs to sample nearly uniform a
so for appropriate definition of nearly
uniform so there is no need to be able
to decode every single bit so the idea
remain ad and this transpiration is to
encode the proof will be appropriate
least locally decodable codes the decode
the constant fraction of proof bits
correctly so they don't decode the whole
proof correctly but there is a constant
fraction that they can decode correctly
so there is a guarantee that they decode
at least a constant fraction and so
approximate locally less decodable codes
when inverse polynomial read are
actually known and they've been used in
other contexts so we use the such a code
and so one observation is that if you
have a code that works against errors
you can make it work against the Rangers
with asymptotically the same rate and
you can have twice as many erasure you
can handle twice as many readers as you
can handle errors so why is this so if
you if you have your readers you can
basically fill the erasers with
uniformly random bits and then in
expectation you're going to get half of
them correct and then you can use the
the approximate miss la política code so
once you have a good list locally
decodable code you can get good least
locally decodable code that works
against the racers so and you can you
can get what we need but the problem so
I guess one of the questions is do you
actually mean the code that works
against errors in order to get the code
of course against the readers so it's
possible that there are could be better
codes that work against the readers
so let me talk about open questions so I
know unless you guys have more questions
so first open question can we get even
stronger separation so constant versus
linear I guess okay so this is what we
have in the other issue of separation
cases so at this point we have constant
versus linear but so here the what we
actually get is constant versus n - 1 v
and this is a basically it depends on
the rate of the code that we used so now
the question is what people ask so can
we get the separation for some natural
property so this property is that we use
artificially constructed now the
question is so other questions that have
to do with a list okay decodable code so
locally at least there is decodable
codes provably better than least locally
decodable codes so we actually have
showed that for Hadamard so in terms of
the list size and the query complexity
we can do better but kind of the big
question is can you get least locally
decodable codes that work against the
ragers with much better rate so we know
that if you have a code that works
against errors it implies the code that
works against the razors with twice as
many corruptions but is the implication
true the other way so if you have if you
can handle handle your readers is it
true that you can also handle errors
okay we do much better so I guess I
would say this this is a big open
question so and I guess constant query
constantly sized local history to
decodable codes with inverse polynomial
rate so this is I mentioned there's a
big question for errors but maybe
perhaps way to attack is the target is
to look at erasers right so it maybe
it's an assembler question
[Applause]
not quite sure the question makes sense
that you studied that can follow where
you don't look at how that registers but
like testers I don't we get so the
question is can you do it for sample
based testing can you separate separate
raised so I'm not sure so I guess
they're there you can ask similar
questions for other models so we did it
for property testing right so but you
can say for for other you take your
favorite model of computation and ask is
it easier to deal with the razor's then
with arbitrary errors so I guess I
cannot answer this out of the top of my
head maybe it's easier to separate
what is the situation around very good
question so we are trying to understand
for graph appropriate testing so we're
working on this with Newton and Ramesh
to my students and with Amit levy so we
have some results so there is some
interesting a threshold phenomena there
okay so the first thing with graph
property testing is some issue that I
kind of he'd put under the carpet here
so but if you go back to the definition
of arisia resilient testing so the way I
defined it on the slide is actually
different and then the way we define it
in the paper but it doesn't matter for
functions and matters for graphs so let
me get back there
so what basically so I said okay so we
want to say yes if it can be completed
to a to something that has the property
and we want to say no if it we want to
reject if any competition is far from
satisfying the property and so how the
fairness is measured so that measured
with respect to the whole string or just
with only non raised part so for
function properties it doesn't matter
but it turns out for graphs it doesn't
matter so basically so for functions it
doesn't matter because you can fill this
the way you want them there are no
restrictions right so if there is you
can just feel the way you want but for
graphs basically there could be some
restriction so if I my graph is
represented in the adjacency list model
then so if I have an erasure for some
vertex it means it has to connect to
some something right so there is some
restriction on how things have to
connect and it's not the case that you
can connect them in an arbitrary way so
there are some interesting questions
right there or E and basically we look
at some simple properties and there are
some interesting fresh hold phenomenon
so basically at some point you for
certain values you cannot test at all
and then when alpha drops become
sufficiently small then you can test
very well so there is some kind of
threshold so we studied only a couple of
properties
okay
[Applause]